hats off to our opposition today they
came back and played a heck of G heck of
a game in the second quarter they went
on to get the victory I'm truly upset
I'm truly uh Disturbed I'm going to try
my best to stay composed and do the best
of my ability to handle this press
conference cuz you deserve my best and
I'm going to try my best to give it to
you uh started off the game wonderfully
finally put it together in the first
half like I desired like we desired like
our players desired and the fans uh
wonderful first half uh 29 nothing I
believe the score was am I correct and
uh you
surrender I believe three touchdowns
unanswered close to it which I can't
fathom right now I'm still trying to
wrap my head around it and then the
thing just steep kept going uh left I
mean at at at at halftime I I talked to
him
about you know the old cliche people say
Z Z but that's not true it's not 0 0 29
nothing but I felt complacency going
into the half because uh we stalled
offensively we gave up some yardage as
well and uh just in like how I felt
going in at halftime we come back out
and here comes the complacency here
comes that team that I can't stand that
you can't stand that you can't
understand how in the world that happens
to us but it did and uh didn't turn it
back on I think until late in the fourth
quarter when we were able to go down and
get a score and we go down and then they
tied up and we got overtime and you
don't want to go in overtime because
they they have nothing to lose nothing
to lose I was surprised that they kicked
the field goal the first time I thought
they was just going to go for two and
try the best to get it over with but
they were resilient Big Win by them uh
horrible loss by us just simply put I
mean how does this team go forward after
a after a defeat like you have no choice
but to go forward that's life
this ain't the only thing that's going
on in life I mean all you guys are
dealing with something you still moving
you still progressing you're still going
forward we got to do the same DN thing
we didn't expect that there a lot of
things that goes on in life that's
unexpected and this is one of them we
got to knuckle up and let's go we can't
sit down and have no pity party y'all
don't feel bad for us some of y'all are
ecstatic about what transpired today and
I know that but that's cool we going to
take this one on the chin cuz we deserve
it um 29 I I I I never been in one of
these type I I don't remember a I from
youth on i w remember being up 29
nothing and losing a football game I
really don't this is this is a little
tough for me and I'm trying my best and
I thank you all for your patience and I
thank you for your your heart because
this is really tough for me but you can
see when I'm amping up and I kind of see
this stuff coming you can see why I go
at it like I go at it because I could
feel my team I could feel what's about
to transpire and here we go